[inaudible]
the full rights and Germany are two
things that sound pretty scary.
You when you put them together.
This is why even though Angela Merkel
has won the elections with a high
margin,
it has been a bittersweet victory.
The facts,
the alternative for Germany,
a Zena phobic,
ultra conservative party has become the
third largest political force is bad
enough to make merkel rather uneasy.
We don't need to beat around the bush.
We wanted a better result.
That is clear.
Angela Merkel it revision policy,
what we plan to do a video this week
about Germany,
but the current news,
forster,
stupid spoon,
that video so we could have time to
prepare this one explaining what's an
alternative for journey or afd as it's
known in Germany is all about and yes,
I probably know what you're thinking
right now.
You're probably thinking,
come on Simon and how could you not
predict that the far right would be a
big hit in Germany because well,
at the end of the day,
Zena phobic parties that pretty much in
fashion all across Europe plus afd did
great in previous local elections.
Nevertheless,
most of the polls said that Germans love
moderation above all else,
and that's not just the electoral polls
talking,
but also sociological studies.
For instance,
while in France,
only 50% of the population places
themselves on the center of the
spectrum.
This number in Germany is as high as 76%
for the Germans have many reasons to be
happy.
They almost didn't suffer at all during
the economic crisis and now that our
economy is doing better than ever,
it's salaries are rising,
there's almost full employment and
companies export abroad as if there was
no tomorrow.
So the big question here becomes who
votes for the far right wing in Germany
and most important of all,
what is the alternative for Germany
wants?
Are they really a radical party or is
the media exaggerating?
Well,
today we're going to answer all of those
questions,
but as usual before we get started,
let's have a look at the history.
A party on the divide.
Yes,
it is true today alternative for
Germany.
They are a populist political party with
a big focus on rejecting immigrants and
refugees specifically.
They want to reject those who come from
Islamic countries,
but just by all of this,
it's origins couldn't be more different
than what it is today.
Let's go back to the year 2013 now.
Back then,
all the European media talks about was
the debt crisis that was happening in
countries like Spain,
Italy,
and it's specially Greece now.
In case you don't know the history here,
let's have a quick summary.
Before 2008 German banks invested a lot
of money in lending to companies and
governments in the south of Europe,
and it's after the financial crisis of
2008 these countries couldn't give the
money back.
In fact,
they needed even more cash so that they
could afford their current spending.
This included things like the salaries
of civil servants,
highways and hospitals,
and as you can imagine,
paying day to day spending with debt.
It's a far from ideal situation.
So this is where Angela Merkel comes
along and says,
all right guys,
I'm going to lend you the money.
I will even let you give it back
whenever you want,
but you've got to make some reforms.
See your economic systems.
These reforms,
they were known as austerity.
Germany,
alongside with other northern European
countries,
wanted to lend money to Italy,
Spain,
and Greece,
while at the same time demanding some
budget cuts so that these countries
would no longer need to borrow as much
money in the future and so that they can
pay back their debts.
Those conditions.
They were seen as pretty draconian by
most of those southern European
countries.
They were asking the question,
well,
whose Germany to tell us how we should
spend our money?
Meanwhile,
some Germans,
they were also pretty mad at their
governments.
I mean,
they were thinking,
who are you merkel to go around giving
money to everyone?
This is the European Union,
not an NGO.
Now,
among those angry Germans,
there were three famous economists,
Alexander Garlands,
Burn luck,
and Conrad Adam.
These were the founders of the party
electorial alternative 2013 which would
later become an alternative for Germany.
Any of these first supporters were
bankers and university professors from
the western part of Germany,
cities like Frankfurt,
Cologne and bond,
and do you remember this?
Because it's going to become really
important later on
now in the electoral roll manifesto,
they suggested that Germany should leave
the euro and go back to the German mark
as well.
Why was that?
Well,
this is because they believe that they
could avoid bailouts to porter economies
by doing so and even more importantly,
they could protect their economy from a
luckily devaluation of the euro.
As we've said in previous videos,
Germany success was partly due to their
strong currency
pain and Greece.
They were pushing the European central
banks print more money so that they
could pay their debts back and as you
probably know,
economists,
they thought that was a pretty bad idea.
The first stereotypical afd voters
weren't like the stereotype of an
extreme right wing hooligan.
They were considered to be businessmen,
economists,
and university teachers.
This is why the media started calling
this party,
that quote to Teachers Party and why
they couldn't win a single MP during the
federal elections of 2013 I mean,
think about it,
and monetary policy has not exactly a
sexy topic for an electoral campaign.
I mean pretty much only you're going to
be watching this video care about that
kind of stuff.
Okay.
Nonetheless,
the phase of alternative for Germany,
it was to change in July of 2015 at that
moment,
the economist burn lot of course the
chairman bar to the brand new leader,
frauke petry,
she had other plants.
I'd like the previous Cedars Petrie came
from the eastern part of the country and
this means she brought eight hopefully
different political culture for her
monetary policy deficits and fiscal
responsibility wasn't really,
that's important.
Instead,
she knew there was a big Nisha voters
who wanted an iron fist on things like
immigration and national identity.
Besides these kinds of suggestions would
give her the support of other leaders
like Nigel Farrage from Britain's Ukip
Party,
Marine Le Pen from the National Front in
France,
and of course our favorite politician
than the visual politic mascot.
Yes,
my dear viewer.
Of course we are talking about the one
and only
you up
Germany's far right wing party meets
Putin allies in,
yeah,
Moscow.
I know,
I know Vladimir Putin is an ever popular
topic here at visual politic.
That's what I mean.
How can we resist talking about him?
No.
During this time,
thousands of refugees from Syria,
Iraq and Libya,
they came to Germany,
Angela Merkel,
she welcomes them with arms wide open
and well some Germans,
they didn't really like this,
so in the regional elections of 2016
I'll tell him this.
If the Germany launched an electoral
platform,
which had nothing to do with what the
founders had in mind at the beginning,
this is why many of those economists,
they jumped ship among them.
Luck.
It was the first presidents,
pardon,
has fallen irretrievably into the wrong
hands band.
Luca since then,
alternative for Germany has had two
factions fighting each other.
On the one hand,
we have the people leftover from the
first group,
but they are less and less important to
everyday ends.
On the other hand,
we have those who came under the
leadership of Frauke petry.
This new political structure.
It does mean more voters,
but it also means more problems.
Sorry.
The ftes,
current crisis was triggered in mid
January through a tableau breaking
speech by right when you're bjorn hookah
who in a beer hall and dressed in call
for 180 degree turn in Germany's culture
of remembering and atoning for the Nazi
era regardless of how far right when you
want it to be.
These kinds of things then not really
cool in Germany and this created many
problems from this is patrick.
There are some investigations open
because apparently some of the proposals
on her program might be illegal.
Remember that German law is made to
avoid any resurgence of Nazis.
The issues in this party are big enough
that even Fralca pitcher you herself had
to resign one day after this last
election due to in fighting with some of
the more extreme factions of things
party.
Nevertheless,
with or without the unfortunate quote,
Sam's,
the internal division,
Alzheimer's.
If for Germany,
it has become the big surprise from this
election.
So the question now becomes,
oh,
voted for them.
Well,
let's take a look at this history of
two.
Germany's for the past few years,
the German economy has been on fire,
salaries are growing,
companies are exporting and inequality
is almost nonexistent.
Well,
actually just hold on for my own because
that last bit,
it's not exactly sure.
Now of course there is almost no poverty
on the streets and that our factories
all over the country,
but when we look at the income
distribution by regions,
do you see a clear division?
If you pay attention to this map,
you'll see a part,
the red part,
it's a bleed.
Pause is the wealthiest.
The red part is the poorest.
The blue part is what used to be western
Germany and the red part is what used to
be eastern Germany,
communist Germany or that eastern part
of the country is the Germany,
the wing capitalist in 1989 but still
doesn't have the same standard of living
as the west.
If you visit a city like Dresden in
eastern Germany,
you will see lots of construction going
on.
Most of the buildings they were
completed just a couple of years ago,
this is indicative that the
reunification of Germany,
it's still very much an ongoing process.
Now,
of course,
if we compare these standards of living
of an eastern German with a Greek or a
Spaniard,
it doesn't look that bad,
but it's Germans.
They like to be compared with other
Germans,
and when you do that,
things look,
wait,
wes,
she made,
doesn't have enough industrial
opportunity and it lacks proper
educational facilities.
A large sport and cultural center aren't
enough to keep people from leaving the
city.
It's dead quiet in the town center.
Young people have left in droves for
bigger cities in the west.
A sculpture on the riverbank mirrors the
city's troubled hopes for the future.
In this city,
the city of sweat alternative for
Germany got over 20% of the votes and
Julissa further south in the state of
Saxony.
Most people are voting for the far
right,
but hold on a minute because we're not
just talking about the economy here.
We're talking about a totally different
culture.
Think about it.
East Germans lived for entire
generations under a totally different
political system.
This means a different education,
a different lifestyle and different
values here.
Moderation.
It's not really a good thing.
In fact,
of the left wing party day,
Linka gets most of its votes in eastern
Berlin,
but there's more than that.
Well,
western German spent decades remembering
their Nazi past.
The government of the Democratic
Republic of Germany tried to create a
new sense of national pride.
So when an afd candidate says that,
we must appreciate the courage of the
German soldiers during World War Two
Germans from Cologne or frightened,
but Germans from Leipzig say,
well,
okay,
whatever.
All right,
but now there is a really important
question.
Why is eastern Germany is so much
against refugees and immigrants?
Well,
many of you might think this is because
they are tired of Muslims who don't want
to integrate into their culture.
Right?
Well,
here comes a number that is going to
absolutely blow your minds.
There aren't 9 million immigrants living
in Germany and less than 500,000 in East
German.
And when you're ready,
think about it.
This makes total sense.
I mean those,
he moved to Germany,
they want to be in the wealthiest
regions.
So if you walked down the streets of
Dresden,
you're hardly ever going to see a woman
covering her head with a hijab.
And then guess who is the biggest
immigrant community in eastern Germany?
While surprise,
surprise,
that would be the Russians.
Well then half of the immigrants living
on this side of the country,
it come from the lands of Putin and of
course they are the biggest audience for
German,
Russia,
Allan's well,
this explains things like this.
FD Deploys Double Headed Eagle to snare
Russian German voters.
So now the question becomes,
do you think alternative for Germany can
keep growing in the next election or
we'll it's internal divisions end up
destroying the party.
And what do you think this part you can
achieve over the next four years?
Please do let us know in the comments
section below.
Meanwhile,
if you want to know why Germany is the
wells factory,
do click on this video and also around
or to visit the reconsider media
podcast.
They provided the vocals in this video
that are not mine.
And as always,
we publish new videos every Monday and
Thursday.
So you hit that subscribe button and you
will not miss any of those videos.
And don't forget to give us a thumbs up
if you enjoyed this video.
And as always,
I'll see you in the next one.
And if you want to learn more about
politics and hear even more of my love
the voice,
you can join us at reconsider media.
We have a podcast,
I've reconsidered media.com/podcast CNA.